لماذا يحتاج التلاميذ الى تعلم الكتابه
الخطيه بعد اليوم مدام يستطيعون الكتابه
بالنقر على مفاتيح الكمبيوتر والاجهزه
اللوحيه وما دام الذكاء الاصطناعي
والرقمنه قد اصبح جزءا من الانظمه
التعليميه في عدد من الدول سؤال ملح اذا
علمنا ان الدول مثل فنلندا والمكسيك
والعديد من الولايات الامريكيه الغت
بالفعل دروس الكتابه الخطيه من المناهج
الدراسيه وان بعض البحوث وعلى عكس
الاعتقاد السائد وجدت ان فعل الكتابه
الخطيه لا يؤثر على نمو قدرات القراءه
بشكل افضل من الكتابه الرقميه
وان نتائج القراءه تكون عاده متشابهه
تماما بين التلاميذ بغض النظر عن طريقه
الكتابه التي استخدموها خطيه كانت ام
رقميه
وجدت دراسه استقصائيه امريكيه شملت اكثر
من الف معلم والف طالب اعمارهم بين 12
عاما وسبعه عشر ان غالبيه المعلمين
والطلاب الذين شملهم الاستطلاع يوافقون
على ان تشاد هو مجرد مثال اخر على ضروره
عدم الاستمرار في الطرق القديمه للتعلم
ولكن اذا كانت ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي
قادره على تقديم اجابات سريعه وسهله
للاسئله فهل لديها القدره على بناء مهارات
التفكير النقدي وحل المشكلات التي تعتبر
ضروريه للنجاح الاكاديمي والحياه واذا
انعدمت القدره على الكتابه الخطيه لدى
الطالب الا يعد ذلك حرمانا له من الارتباط
المادي بالنص الذي يكتبه
الا تريحه الكتابه الخطيه من التحديق في
شاشه ساطعه لفترات طويله من الزمن الا
تساعد الكتابه الخطيه الطالبه على التركيز
واستيعاب المعلومات التي يقراها بشكل اكثر
فعاليه من الكتابه الرقميه في كل الاحوال
قد يبدو من السابق لاوانه تحديد التاثير
الدائم للكتابه الرقميه فتطبيق مثل تشات
لم يكن موجودا قبل فصل دراسي واحد لكن ما
هو مؤكد هو ان روبوتات المحادثه موجوده
وستبقى